foreign
how many of you have heard of the fire
movement some of you are going whoa
where is this going what does this have
to do with money well that's an acronym
George it stands for financially
independent
retired early and you know about all
these things here Mr Financial Trend
nothing gets over on you I've read the
blogs I've seen the tweets you've seen
it all and so this is a movement where
people essentially work themselves
to almost exhaustion and Beyond
and the ideas in their 20s and 30s
they're working like crazy socking
everything away saving living on way
less than they make something that we
obviously love
but they have no life
and the idea is is that they never work
again
which is counter-intuitive to what I
believe to be true what we Ramsey
Solutions believe that you were created
to work uh to contribute if you will and
uh so uh this is a headline here I've
got in my hands this is a uh make sure I
oh this is a finance
uh Yahoo article there the team hates
when I do that guys it's just an old
paper tactic it's going to be okay it's
all right they get so alarmed nobody
wants to hear the paper I think they do
I do it on my show all the time I love
it
do you guys like the paper crinkle out
there it's it's overwhelming in the lot
the lobby guests are like Zach likes
that one okay very good all right so
here's a story in my hands here uh of a
couple uh that is now well
shall we say regretting this decision
they retired early George with 4.3
million dollars
but now this is their quote we don't
want to just keep throwing money on the
pile and being cheap so they want to
live but they're afraid to spend and uh
so this is a scarcity mentality that the
the the the man says in the couple it's
Carl and Mindy and um uh they they
retired six years ago with 4.3 million
dollars saved uh and so uh they focused
on doing several things flipping real
estate uh they socked away a bunch of
money they still have a bunch of assets
and blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
but they're not living in a way that
they would like to
and so your thoughts on this George
because I mean this is there's another
story I will get to this in a second but
I mean this doesn't always work out for
people it sounds great
but then you work and you skip out on so
much life
then you're then you're living life on
your terms except except maybe you
aren't well like you mentioned there is
some Crossover with our principles and
the fire movement principles which is
live on less than you make increase your
income invest and save the difference be
on a budget spend wisely well these
people have taken that to an extreme
that is very unhealthy and so the idea
here is hey Ken what if in our 30s we
could have three million dollars and
just live off of that and never have to
work a day again here's the problem with
that you could live another 60 years so
now you're trying to Penny pinch to make
this millions of dollars last 60 years
while going uh what do we fill in our
time with other than worrying about
money yeah so the idea is to stop
worrying about money and yet here they
are worrying about money because of a
scarcity mentality so we believe there's
a balance there and Ken of course is
always preaching that we were created to
contribute
networking is actually good for us and
I'm in the boat of uh you know enjoy
your life and so if you have to live
this scarcity mindset life to make it
work so that you can retire from working
for the man it was a bad plan to begin
with that's right and I think retirement
and this may be an unpopular opinion but
I'll put it out there I don't think
retirement
um is what it's cracked up to be if your
whole goal is just to not work as
opposed to how do you want to live like
it's not about not working but that's
for a lot of people what retirement is I
just don't want to work well it should
be about so much more than that and I
think that uh the well I don't think I
know the data uh plays out that when
people stop working for enjoyment
they're not doing something productive
and I'm not talking just hobbies that
your overall health suffers so this idea
that I'm just gonna I'm Gonna Save and
live uh no enjoyment just so I never
have to work again it's never going to
play out well for people in fact in then
financially it doesn't either Sam Dogan
who is one of the you know forefathers
of this movement retired 11 years ago
with three million dollars and uh big
news it's in this article and it came
out probably a couple months ago I
covered on my show that now he's so
worried about being able to pay for the
cost of his kids who are little they're
Toddlers and he's projecting that
tuition which has steadily gone up
uh over the you know last decade that's
going to be so much that he's not gonna
have any money to live off of and so now
he's coming back for one reason only to
cover college education and again
there's no joy there's no as Thomas
Jefferson wrote The Pursuit of Happiness
here it's just that scarcity mindset
well and he says I started doing some
research and learned that happiness is
mostly something that comes from you it
comes from the inside not an external
Factor ah so he figured this out after
some research or what Thomas Jefferson
uh there you go new all along so here's
what people long for in retirement is
freedom
I think he should continue to work
you've asked me this before I'm not
going to retire
what's your long-term game plan I mean
you're nowhere close you look great you
look like a spry 41. I appreciate that
uh but but I I'm am I going to work less
sure will I keep the hours and and the
intensity uh probably not but but not
far off because I there'd be something
as I get older where I can work and
contribute and see purpose and and
experience meaning and that's good for
my overall health and uh well people
have a negative view of work Ken that's
the problem they're doing something they
hate well that's right uh they're not
doing the right kind of work they're not
doing it at the right place they're
working for the wrong leaders that's
right they're not treated right that's a
very good point there so a lot of
factors that play into this where you're
going hey what if we could find you a
place that you actually enjoy being at
with people you respect with good
leadership and work that you're
passionate about yeah I I remember
meaning uh when we lived in Atlanta I
got to tell you this story about Martha
so Martha was 76 and she worked in the
local Chick-fil-A that we went to with
our kids
right off of Peachtree Industrial
Boulevard right there in Suwanee Georgia
all right and I asked her one time she
was so kind and so sweet it was like she
was like everybody's grandma and I asked
her I was like why do you do this she
goes because I just love being here with
people and serving and working in a way
that just makes people feel comfortable
and I know that I'm making a difference
she was always walking around every
table can I get you a refill can I turn
in your children's book for the ice
cream you know these are very important
things that you're going to be dealing
with not to oh I don't know about that I
don't have kids yet and I still do that
you always go get the ice cream that's
my hack uh so so it's it's and she just
said I just love showing up and being a
part of this team that's the idea and
she did it part time you know not
because she had to because she wanted
well you've asked this question Ken what
would you do if money was was not a
factor yeah that gets you dreaming and
usually whatever that thing is
it involves making money if you can make
good money doing that it does and here's
the other thing in retirement when if
you've lived like no one else so later
you can live and give like no one else's
we teach you you won't need the money
but you you'll need the engagement you
go do that then you've got extra money
you've got that extra spending money you
don't even it's just what do you do with
it you can give it away you do a lot of
fun things and I think that that's
really important so there's a lot of
themes here generosity being one of
generosity is a huge people that's the
key to Joy not consuming and trying to
uh
achieve some level of wealth the other
one is contentment and the other one is
moderation going hey maybe it's not good
for us to spend everything we make and
be broke maybe it's not good for us to
live on so little that we live in a
scarcity mentality on the fritz all the
time maybe we should just be on a budget
and assign some line items for things
like vacations and things like eating
out you can do that once you're out of
debt and let's have a plan to retire
with some dignity to where we can do
some really cool things and take the
kids on Amazing vacations and so I think
our plan has a really nice balanced
approach it really does uh but you know
for a lot of these folks they're going
to look back and go I don't have enough
money and I don't remember doing
anything in my 30s other than working
which by the way are some of your best
years you know health-wise physically
30s 40s career-wise and so to squander
that by trying to get to this goal so
quickly I think hurts people mentally
financially I agree emotionally all of
it you make a good point you know your
30s is still a wonderful decade of
testing I'm in it and Discovery I'm
living it and seeing who you are and
really preparing for that second half of
your life if you're blessed to have